[Music]
In order to go back to the future, I need a new sword. I need to find a new sword.
Why do you have this? You
keep it because you deserve it. You
save people with this.
Who are you? This is the person who becomes that woman's acupressure. This isn't the first time, Imoi them.  I saved you, yes, that's right. You, that
little boy, my water.
When I went up the hill after saving you, I saw something strange. If there
is a monster inside me, what am I? I have to kill this guy before the yoga comes out. Let's go to the
future. Now the bar will
explode and the beasts will attack. Let's
start. Where are we? Is it the future? Is it
the opposite sex?  Become a king or
not? It wasn't just an accident. Let's go
14 minutes before the explosion. Ian will
solve it. It's like other
humans.
What should I do?
[Music]